regardless of any personal scenarios in
my own life being a woman and reading
stories of other women who experience
this that in itself is it's
heartbreaking it's atrocious but what
makes it all the more detrimental and
serious is that so many of these women
felt they had to stay silent this is an
issue that we as women need to stand up
against and we need to rally the men
around us to support us in standing up
against this and we need to come
together not just as women and not just
as men but as a united force of humanity
to really say enough is enough this
behavior is not going to be tolerated it
is not funny it is not a joke it's
extremely serious and we have to we have
to see it end now
and I think so many women in the past
have you know looked over their shoulder
and and been scared of being judged by
you know people of power what people
would say and I think there's a lot of
men as well who are probably
reevaluating what they've done in the
past and I think this is a time for us
to all come together and say let's be
better in the future let's do our part
to create change and let's definitely
take this seriously and not let this be
something that blows over it's a very
important matter and something that will
be incredibly important for our future
and for the next generation